il y en a mais le bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors depuis le 8
juillet en autriche la confrérie des
frères musulmans est inscrite sur la
liste des groupes extrémistes est lié à
la criminalité à motivation religieuse
alors qu'est ce qui a motivé ce choix
des autorités qu'est ce qu'on reproche
précisément aux frères musulmans
il ya d'abord eu l'attentât du 2 2
novembre 2000 2020 qui a fait quatre
morts
ensuite il faut savoir que les frères
musulmans se sont intéressés à
l'autriche depuis les années 1970 à peu
près c'est là qu'il ya quelqu'un j'y
retrouvais son livre qui s'appelle
youssef nada qui est un des dirigeants
qui était le dirigeant suprême des
frères musulmans en europe qui s'est
installée en autriche pour faire du
business
or youssef nada c'est pas c'est pas un
guerrier youssef nada c'est un homme
d'affaires c'est quelqu'un c'est le thé
le financier des frères musulmans
pour comprendre ce que sont les frères
musulmans s'est retrouvé une phrase la
semaine bana donc le fondateur vous avez
cité inca créer les frères musulmans
1928 en égypte il déclarait la bannière
dallas sera arboré au dessus de
l'occident et la méditerranée
redeviendra islamique
donc je crois qu'ils sont très très
clairs les frères musulmans c'est la
conquête du mid
pourquoi ce qui s'est passé mais
pourquoi précisément l'autriche pourquoi
elle est devenue un siège finalement la
confrérie des frères musulmans
je crois que c'est un petit peu par
hasard au départ youssef nada a été
arrêté dans les années 1950 4,56 il
s'est ensuite enfui en libye et il est
resté en libye il a commencé à faire du
business et en libye quand est arrivé
kadhafi s'est enfui leed il est est ce
qu'en fit il est passé par la grèce et
ensuite il s'est installé en autriche
et c'est là je veux dire qu'il a
développé son business aussi bien dans
le fromage dans les ca vous fera rire
mais dans le ciment et les devenu
milliardaire
et c'est à partir de là que beaucoup de
frères musulmans se sont effectivement
implanté en autriche mais là c'était du
business au départ c'était pas pour
mener des actions terroristes et le
le point de départ de cette nouvelle loi
c'est en novembre 2020
quand les contient un attentat qui fait
quatre morts comment la confrérie des
frères musulmans dans le pays et dans le
monde d'ailleurs a réagi à cette annonce
jeudi ils ont pas tellement apprécié
pour l'instant que pour l'instant il
faut voir qu'il n'y avait que l'egypte
d'abord le l'arabie saoudite les émirats
arabes unis et bahreïn qui interdisait
les frères musulmans même les états unis
le dire malgré des crampes déclarations
de donald trump ils ont jamais interdit
encore une fois c'est très compliqué
d'interdire une organisation parce qu'il
faut pas oublier que les frères
musulmans ne aucun frères musulmans ne
se déclare usuellement justement très
concrètement comment ça va se passer en
autriche qu'est ce qu'ils vont devenir
les membres des frères musulmans
est-ce qu'ils vont être frappés par
certaines interdictions comment ça va se
passer
alors quand vous voyez les textes c'est
pas exactement une interdiction des
frères musulmans de l'organisation parce
qu'encore une fois ils vous diront
qu'ils sont pas frères musulmans
c'est une une interdiction des symboles
les symboles sais pas si vous voyez ce
que sont les symboles des frères
musulmans c'est notamment la rabia c'est
à dire que quand ils font cela quand
vous voyez le président r douanes dans
les foules il fait ça ça ça c'est la
rabia c'est le signe de ralliement des
frères musulmans est également le
symbole qui est le plus connu
c'est un coran avec deux sabres qui
s'entrecroisent derrière voilà c'est ça
a véritablement donc finalement ça va
pas les empêcher d'exister sait que
c'est toujours compliqué d'exister parce
que la personne nous dira je ne suis pas
frères musulmans et l'association se
déclarera déclara qu'elle n'est pas
frères musulmans vous avez musulmans de
france qu'elle a des frères musulmans
musulmans dans l'hexagone genoux les
interviewés je vous dise non nous les
connaissons mais nous nous ne sommes pas
frères musulmans s clairement pas les
empêcher de se manifester
est ce que d'autres pays européens
pourraient s'inspirer de cette décision
autrichienne je pense que l'allemagne
sera la première à s'inspirer de
deux exemples autrichien autre manche
voit difficilement la france elle l'a
pas fait le fera pas dans un court terme
l'autriche qui reste dans le seul pays
d'europe à accorder finalement un statut
officiel al islam est ce qu'on sait
comment cette décision d'interdire les
frères musulmans a été perçue sur place
écoutez c'est un peu trop tôt si vous
lisez
si vous regardez la presse autrichienne
pour l'instant il n'y a pas énormément
d'éléments assez compliqué de voir
comment comment ça va réagir je crois
qu'il ya ça représente et musulmans
représentent malgré tout me % de la
population 1 mais ça sera important de
voir comment seront les réactions et
comment les frères musulmans vont réagir
et comment je dis rivaux ils ont tenté
de se restructurer
merci beaucoup ian hamel pour tous ces
précisions je le rappelle vous êtes
journaliste d'investigation
correspondant du point à genève et
spécialiste des affaires financières et
de l'islam radical